[Music]
[Applause]
mel keiper draft expert joining us on
the program mel i was just talking about
the packers bringing in sammy watkins
does that change anything they do
in the first round
well i think they needed three receivers
dan going into the draft i had them
taken a couple won the first one in the
second i still think they attack it that
way
sami is a veteran obviously they need
some young receivers coming into this
program and this is a great draft for
wide receivers stand up basically into
the fifth six round area you're gonna
find guys that can help you so i gave
them i thought two really good ones and
christian watson and alec pierce guys
with length they can come in smart kids
that can come in and help them right
away for aaron rodgers so i still think
because of the the best position in this
draft and the deepest being wide
receiver you got to take advantage of it
if you're the packer so i think they
will despite that move i think they're
going to say two maybe three receivers
selected over the seven rounds is that
the uh
uh position where you feel like
throughout as you said first five rounds
that if you didn't get one in the first
or second that you could get value in
the third or fourth or fifth round
i believe you can a slot and wide then
calvin austin the third is not only fast
but he catches the football consistently
he's got punt return ability uh he's a
little bit like hollywood brown while he
was a first round pick calvin austin the
third will probably be a third round
pick wandel robinson from kentucky
formerly of nebraska's electrifying kid
slot guy he will probably be a third or
fourth rounder khalil shakir from boise
state's another one an underrated guy i
think is isaiah weston from northern
iowa i mentioned alec pierce in the
second round a kid with with length with
great athletic ability ran 4-4 averaged
over 17 yards of catch mechanical
engineering major you know athletic
family i mean these are these are some
really good players dana you normally
would never see in the second or third
round of a draft but this year you will
who are you still trying to figure out
is there
a player
yes there's a there's a few in fact
that's a great question dan because i
don't get that question that often but
there are always guys that you just
don't know you really can't figure out
and then you know those are guys just
don't draft if you're a team because if
you can't figure them out if you come to
the conclusion we don't know what type
of player this player this kid will be
we don't know how he fits i'll go right
to trayvon walker of georgia trayvon
could be the first second third pick in
this draft uh people are still talking
about him is going maybe going number
one so again here's a kid who had nine
and a half career sacks 13 career
tackles for loss had a ton of hurries he
was disruptive but then the finishing
numbers aren't there the versatility is
there they moved them around i didn't
see the quickness outside i saw the
quickness more inside so you look at the
numbers compared to you know miles
garrett clowney the bose of brothers
they're it's not even close in the
production during their career over the
same time period so you're betting on
the talent which is awesome a 6'5 270
incredible athletic ability incredible
speed great kid you're betting on a
coach in the nfl that's why they have
coached before their name
getting the most out of trayvon walker
figuring out what position he's going to
maximize that ability at and then taking
a kid who i said nine and a half career
sacks 13 career tackles lost and turning
him in against the best lineman in the
world into a guy who can be a
double-digit sack guy in one season
that's going to be a challenge for the
team to drastic and i think another kid
that is definitely tough to evaluate
based on you know where he is in terms
of of the smaller cousin with one double
a is trevor penning i like trevor
penning but he's got to improve he's got
to get more bend he can't be as
aggressive as he was going after people
after the whistle he's got to settle
down a bit improve his technique if he's
going to be a left tackle coming out of
northern iowa a lot of people think and
i do think he can go 16 in new orleans
or 17 to the charger so a ton of talent
i love the nastiness i love the fire he
plays with but i think he's got to
settle down a bit and certainly i say
improve that technique to be a great uh
pass blocker from the left tackle
position in the nfl i talked to a scout
and uh i i asked him about malik willis
and he said he's a tough read for me
because he did well against competition
where he was the best athlete on the
field but when he wasn't the best
athlete on the field he struggled a
little bit so how do you
grade rationalize what malik willis did
at liberty
i think this now i think the first part
of the season last year he looked like a
top five pick maybe a number one pick
overall uh the second half he was making
some bad decisions some bad throws he
had interceptions against middle
tennessee state three three against
louisiana monroe and he struggled
obviously he knew the team would
struggle against ole miss in that game
though dan he drew the respect of the
rebel defensive players chance campbell
heck of a linebacker coming out of ole
miss played at my high school calvert
hall was great player chance is one of
the has football iq through the roof
he's like a defensive coordinator on the
field he went right up to malik willis
after that game and said boy you are
deceptively fast you're deceptively
strong you're a great player i really
respect the talent you have and he was
just amazing so i couldn't run and
chance can run chances are the four
fives and he he said this kid is fast
he's powerful you know he's got that
compact frame
tough to bring to the ground uh in a
senior bowl danny they had the ball like
the 40-yard line and that was when the
end of the first quarter when it was
like the end of the half so he starts
running they say okay why are you
running okay you got to get a touchdown
here you throw it up for grabs right you
try to get it he almost ran in a chad
mumma from wyoming tackled him at the
five yard line or he would have taken it
from the 40 in on that last play of that
quarter so he's a talent he's got a
great tremendous character yes you know
is he nfl ready now he needs a little
work possibly we always say that about
everybody and sometimes the guys you
think are nfl ready turn out to be some
guys you think the guys at the nfl or
nfl rate do nothing josh rosen being one
of them so uh to me dan somebody's gonna
take him hi i'm going to caroline at six
we'll see he's gonna be a fun one to
watch because pittsburgh sits at 20. and
there are still people out there who
think he could slide down to 20 to mike
tomlin and the steelers
and pittsburgh you have taking kenny
pickett if uh pickett's still left there
on the board we're talking to mel kuiper
draft expert i'm also wondering when you
when you first started this at the
mothership you you were you were saying
where you thought players were going to
go or you were great you were grading
them it wasn't you changed in
where you thought the team what the
teams were going to do do i have that
right the the time frame
yeah i think dan what you always try to
do and i did this when i put out the
draft reports back in 78 79 80 and all
those years i always had a mock first
round right which was trying to predict
what teams would do and i always had a
first round based on what i would do if
i were the gm as we move through the
draft and todd and i are going to do
that we're going to do a three-round
rotate rotating through todd makes it
back i make the pick for that team based
on who's available and what we would do
not trying to match what's going to
happen come april 28th so but it was
confusing to people i said okay i don't
get it well i said well this is what i
would do and this is what the teams will
do but it was confusing to an extent so
the mock giraffes are strictly trying to
match what teams will do come april 28th
the ratings boards i have my big board
up on espn.com every week updated every
couple weeks that's strictly my feeling
dan has nothing to do with where i don't
grade players based on where they're
going to be drafted i grade them based
on ability
stack them up whatever happens happens
that has nothing to do with trying to
figure out a mock draft and where kids
may go
uh how did you have baker mayfield
ranked coming out of oklahoma he was
right i had uh josh allen had one of the
highest grades i ever gave a quarterback
i had him number one and had sam too and
at mayfield right after that so it was
josh allen's draft for me i thought josh
allen when i predicted even the morning
of the draft i thought he would go
number one
i thought the cleveland browns would
take josh allen uh yeah i heard that
wasn't necessarily going to be sandor i
did not think that was that was one of
the curveballs it's fun to get then
don't i remember the morning of the
draft everybody said it's going to be
baker mayfield i did not see that coming
and i said i had i had a mock draft came
out that morning josh allen uh going
number one he was my highest rated crew
he was one of my top 10 highest rated
quarterbacks of all time so i did he
ended up being the third quarterback
taken that year so uh it just was a
surprise it was a baker had moved from a
third round pick in august way up didn't
think it would be number one overall but
it was i'll tell you what dan i think
he's getting unfair criticism i i think
it's totally on i understand the
commercials and getting all the hey who
wouldn't take advantage of it if
somebody comes to you and says hey
there's some commercial opportunities
you take them right but
to criticize baker mayfield after this
year based on the pain and what he went
through with that offensive line injured
running backs injured receiver issues
beckham traded to criticize
you know mayfield based on this year
when he almost had that team in the
super bowl two years ago and played
great football i i don't understand it i
can't rationalize it i can't figure it
out then it makes absolutely no sense to
me but
he's taking it personally and he says
he's disrespected this is a business mel
and i think baker would be better served
at just not saying anything
you know that he's the star i you know
i'm i'm a star at oklahoma i'm the
number one overall pick and
you know you can't believe that uh it's
like marriage you know until death do us
part well people get divorced all the
time and that's what happened in the nfl
a younger or better player came along
and they decided they fell in love with
desean watson it's not fair but that's
that's what happens and it just feels
like playing the victim doesn't help him
if i'm a team looking at him unless i go
man he's got a chip on his shoulder he's
going to be balling out this year
i still worry about that
i'm a star
and uh i was disrespected by the by the
cleveland browns
yeah i guess it could have been handled
a little bit differently but kids react
in a way and it's it becomes personal
you're a quarterback dan you're the face
of the organization everybody's talking
about you and you know i tandel i guess
so much and i think he felt like hey
yeah i deserved a little more than i got
i paid i played through significant pain
let's face it dan it's not the right
shoulder but the left affects the right
and everything where if everything would
have been perfect around him and he's
playing through pain maybe he has a
better chance to have some more success
but when you have everything around you
go awry and you're playing through
significant pain and you're gutting it
out and everybody's saying you're
garbage you're trash
you're not very good you're terrible i
don't understand why you don't look at
it and say okay realistically he can't
be great this year there's no way he
could be as good as he was two years ago
why are we expecting him to be what he
was when he couldn't be that and then
rip him for everything he's saying here
and there i i i can't believe baker
mayfield's still out there and doesn't
have a team i just i can't not believe
it somebody's going to get this kid and
i think he may have the last laugh in
this uh he's going to come in he's
always had a chip and his chip is bigger
right now than it's ever been dan so i
but i said i did not have him as the one
or two quarterback but i'm defending
baker because
two years ago he looked like the real
deal he was when he was healthy and that
team was operating on all cylinders and
this year it's just i think i don't get
it i don't get it with a lot of players
at quarterback who they expect way too
much from despite what's going on around
them which a lot of times isn't very
good
i came in the monday of draft week and i
didn't even tell my guys i said i got
breaking news and it's going to blow you
away
and so i had a a great source on this
and he says to me on sunday night he
said the browns are going to take baker
mayfield
oh my god and so i come in and i say to
my guys at like 902. i didn't even tell
him prior to the show i said i want your
reaction i said i know who the cleveland
browns are going to take and then they
guessed who the browns were going to
take and i said
baker mayfield and everybody was like
what
and
and i was with you because i know
seattle was really interested in trading
up to get maybe the rights to josh allen
to be able to draft him with cleveland
and i thought okay i like baker he's
entertaining i just don't think he's the
number one overall pick but i do agree
with you he's not garbage but let me ask
you this would you rather have equal pay
both healthy jimmy garoppolo or baker
mayfield
i would rather have baker mayfield um
you know i just think i think baker his
age where he is what he showed i love
the the competitiveness of baker the
players i mean he can't not like the way
he plays the game like i said this past
year i'm going to give him a mulligan
for uh i'm definitely going to do that
so i think when you look at it dan
what's fun and to go back to like you
were talking about the mock dress and
what you heard that's what i don't
particularly like about what i do what
we all do now it's become a mock giraffe
nation right and it's every and what
happens here this is what happens to me
and i know todd has talked about a
little bit too we sit there and daniel
jeremiah everybody we sit there and and
mike mayak used to even say it mike
would say it to me we sit there on draft
day and we're worried about what do we
do we mock it right do we have it right
what's happening and you're so
preoccupied with your daggone mock and i
even will come then during the draft i
don't even know a player was taking it
would be in the fifth round of day three
and i'll be talking about a kid that i
thought went to a team because i mocked
him there and he didn't go to that
and even a day later after the dress
over i'll still be thinking about this
player being with this team because i
kept hearing it stan mock traps really
screw your mind up they really do i know
i'm kind of done with them
but i've got they just occupy way too
much of my my thought process during the
course of the season and way too much
even right now all right we have a bet
in studio that a quarterback will be
selected in the top 13 picks
okay
what do you think
i would agree how many quarterbacks in
the team
i would say one uh kenny will be i think
it's gonna be interesting if carolina
trades down from six or they they stay
at six do they get and they feel like we
have two quarterbacks we really like
there's all the talk about matt rule
recruited kenny pickett he loves kenny
pickett maybe organizationally we'll see
about malik woods they move down for
canadian one of these two i've always
believed you got to identify one this is
our guy if you like two fine i said when
eli manning and roethlisberger and
rivers came out i thought it'd all be
really good you could be happy with
which one that sell to you well which
one fell ben roethlisberger fell right
justin herbert fell to the chargers josh
allen fell down buffalo went and got him
so the point being i think in this
particular draft the quarterback that
falls
sometimes turns out to be better than
the one that goes higher it'll be
interesting to see how this all shakes
in i went and put willa some people were
sticking a todd head picket going six i
have willis but i do think one of the
quarterbacks goes in the top 13. always
great to talk to you
your best day is always fun and the
questions you ask guys one question you
asked i never have gotten who's the
toughest how who are the tough guys to
evaluate so dan it's a first for me you
did it you're at the top of the board
pal thank you mel that's mel kiper draft
expert